China is the source of COVID, lies constantly
about COVID, and yet may win the global
political battle over COVID because it
exports vaccines while the US doesn't.
The US should utilize our huge advantage
in vaccine technology to help the world.
American vaccines are the world's best. Reported
effectiveness is highest against known variants,
and backed by far more comprehensive data than nearly
all others. By the end of February the US provided
20 million more doses to our population than
China provided to its much larger population.
China is in no rush to distribute its inferior
vaccines at home. It's exporting them though.
The US rightly won't export until most Americans
are vaccinated. That could happen by the end
of July. Then its superior American vaccine should be
offered to key countries, such as Indonesia and its
270 million people. Many lives can be saved if the US
supports international production and distribution
of our vaccines the way we've done so at home, and
the world would see the American system creating
and sharing the solution to a terrible problem. A
problem caused in large part by the Chinese system.
After most Americans are vaccinated should the
US spend money to make our vaccines available
around the world? Let us know in our poll. Also, let
us know what other topics you'd like our scholars
to cover in 60 seconds, and make sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.